the investigation into an unreported  shooting at a state senator and North  Las Vegas mayoral candidate's house has  stalled as Witnesses refused to come  forward following an attempted murder  nearly two weeks ago police arrested  Democratic state senators Pat spearman's  son neon Che Osborne in October they say  he shot his cousin a prior shooting in  September where Osborne reportedly shot  at a wall went unreported North Las  Vegas Police telling our eight news now  investigators quote multiple requests  have been made to interview persons with  information regarding the incident to  date there's been no response end quote  Spearman said in a statement that she  would not be making any more comments  about either shooting